o
então é um enorme prazer estar aqui
falando com vocês
eu sempre sonhei em ser professora
porque eu via nesse sonho na realização
desse sonho
a possibilidade de fazer a diferença na
vida de outras pessoas
eu exerço magistério 24 anos apesar da
minha carinha de 15 o corpo de 16 ea o
parte do tempo eu tive um sentimento de
realização no meu trabalho mas nos
últimos anos
eu enfrentei um profundo sentimento de
tristeza e desânimo frente às
dificuldades que eu vivi em sala de aula
eu percebi que eu precisava me
reinventar como educadora e fiz um
investimento na minha formação
nesse processo de fortalecimento da
minha formação eu me dei conta de que eu
tinha dois grandes desafios a vencer
o primeiro seria superar o modelo
educacional prevalecente que privilegia
muito mais a cópia ea repetição do que a
inovação ea criatividade dos nossos
alunos em algumas escolas passam a maior
parte do tempo correndo do quadro
copiando do livro didático copiando do
caderno do colega e empreendendo pouco
esforço naquilo que de fato promove a
aprendizagem desenvolvimento
o segundo desafio que eu teria que
vencer seria trazer as novas tecnologias
à minha prática pedagógica elas
apareceram aqui o tempo todo os meus
alunos nasceu e vive num mundo
completamente permeado pelas novas
tecnologias
então se eu quisesse fazer um trabalho
que fizesse sentido para eles eu deveria
me apropriar desses recursos
e foi com essa perspectiva e atendendo
também um apelo deles que diziam por
professor você não tem facebook pai
velho e aí eu tive que criar uma página
em uma rede social
eu sou muito avessa às redes sociais mas
eu precisava transformá la numa serra
então pedagógica e em certa ocasião
observando a minha página no facebook
eu me deparei com vídeo produzido e
postado por uma garota de 13 anos no
qual ela se apresentava dançando de
forma muito erotizada a música que era
executada no vídeo a forma como ela
dançava e as roupas que ela vestiam
deram ao vídeo um forte apelo sexual
a menina recebeu milhares de
visualizações
muitos comentários muitas curtidas e o
curioso é que os comentários eram bem
depreciativos bem ofensivos
talvez um pouco parecidos com o que a
valesca colocou aqui e me chamou a
atenção que aquela menina não se
perceber se ofendida ela passou a fazer
outras postagens de outros vídeos e
parecia se sentir valorizada com aquilo
eu fiquei muito intrigado com aquela
situação e fui conversar com outras
pessoas que já transitavam nas redes
sociais há mais tempo que eu e o que
houve foi o seguinte que aquilo já era
tão corriqueiro tão costumeiro que as
pessoas achavam natural como naturalizar
que meninas se expõe nas redes sociais
desse jeito eu compartilho da opinião da
valesca de que o corpo da mulher e o que
ela faz com ele é problema dela mas eu
estava diante de uma menina de 13 anos
em processo de formação e eu fiquei me
perguntando será que essa menina
imagina que esses vídeos podem ser
usados para alimentar sites de
pornografia site de pedofilia
será que ela imagina que dali a alguns
anos quando ela já estiver envolvido em
outros projetos e outros contextos
aquele material que ela postou pode
voltar já que depois que a gente possa
alguma coisa nas redes sociais a gente
perde o controle e ela pode no mínimo se
sentir pouco confortável com isso
eu precisava entender mais sobre aquela
situação e passei a fazer algumas
pesquisas e descobri que aquele
comportamento tem nome e se chama sex
tim e se refere a essa prática muito
recorrente entre adultos jovens
adolescentes de exercitar e descobrir a
própria sexualidade pelas redes sociais
é algo absolutamente saudável natural
o problema é que no caso dos
adolescentes e dos menores de idade
muitas vezes eles o fazem por falta de
uma reflexão mais aprofundada sobre o
uso consciente das redes sociais
muitas vezes eles fazem por mero modismo
por acompanhar uma onda que está nas
redes sociais e o que mais me deixou
preocupada a maioria das meninas
práticos sext nas redes sociais porque
elas reproduzem ou copiam um modelo
feminino representado nas grandes mídias
no qual a mulher é medida pelo quanto
ela é sexualmente desejável e o quanto
ela corresponde a determinados padrões
de beleza
eu sabia que não tinha o direito de
determinar o que aquelas meninas fariam
com as suas imagens
mas como educador eu tinha obrigação de
propor uma reflexão para que pelo menos
elas pudessem fazer escolhas mais
lúcidos e foi assim que surgiu o projeto
mulheres inspiradoras
ele partiu de um princípio muito simples
se os nossos meninos e as nossas meninas
estão tomando para si esse referencial
de mulher que a representa ea mede
apenas pelo quanto ela sexualmente
desejável no caminho possível seria
ampliar o repertório cultural desses
meninos e dessas meninas trazendo outras
referências a partir das quais eles
pudessem se inspirar
o projeto foi desenvolvido com alunos do
soul nos anos numa escola em ceilândia
que fica do lado da casa
eu nasci e me criei portanto eu conheço
bem a comunidade
eu entendi também que pra fortalecer a
formação dos meus alunos
eu precisava fazer um projeto que
privilegiasse a escrita ea leitura
então nós propusemos a leitura de seis
obras de autoria feminina
o diário de anne frank
eu sou malala quarto de despejo diário
de uma favelada de carolina maria de
jesus só por hoje vou deixar o meu
cabelo em paz não vou mais lavar os
pratos
espelhos miradouros e dialética da
percepção esses três últimos a autoria
de uma grande escritora daqui de
brasília cristiano sobral além de propor
a leitura de seis obras de autoria
feminina
eu sugeri também que os meus alunos
conhecessem a biografia de grandes
mulheres que escreveram seus nomes na
história da humanidade
eles conheceram um anne frank a menina
que escreveu um diário e deu voz e
visibilidade aos mais de um milhão de
judeus mortos no período da segunda
guerra mundial
carolina maria de jesus catadora de
papel moradora do morro do canindé que
só estudou até a segunda série se tornou
escritora de best seller teve o seu
livro traduzido para 13 idiomas cora
coralina a doceira de goiás velho que o
chico teve o prazer de conhecer que
começou a escrever poemas aos 14 anos se
reinventou 50 e aos 75 publicou o
primeiro livro se tornando uma das
nossas grandes escritoras irena sendler
a enfermeira polonesa que salvou duas
mil e quinhentas crianças do extermínio
durante o período da dominação alemã em
varsóvia malala a menina paquistanesa
que tem dedicado a sua vida e indefesa
de outras meninas e outros meninos terem
acesso à educação formal
maria da penha a farmacêutica cearense
que sobreviveu a uma tentativa
homicídio praticado pelo seu marido e
tem dedicado a sua vida em favor de
outras mulheres que são vítimas de
violência doméstica
nise da silveira uma das primeiras
mulheres a se tornar médica no brasil o
psiquiatra que revolucionou a
psiquiatria trazendo alternativas de
tratamentos mais humanitários
rosa parks a costureira do alabama nos
estados unidos que em pleno período do
violento aparthaid se recusou a ceder o
seu lugar a um homem branco fortalecendo
a luta pelos direitos civis naquele país
viu darnes a médica de santa catarina
que com medidas simples como a formação
de mulheres em comunidades carentes ea
distribuição do soro caseiro e da
multimistura conseguiu reduzir
drasticamente as taxas de mortalidade
infantil no brasil além de conhecer
essas grandes mulheres
os alunos foram convidados também a
conhecerem mulheres da própria
comunidade
eu levei a escola duas grandes e
duradouras
o escritor e uma médica com uma relação
muito próxima com a nossa cidade para
que os meninos pudessem se inspirar
mas uma outra ação do projeto muito
importante foi convidá los a refletir
sobre o círculo do convívio deles eles
deveriam escolher uma mulher que eles
considerassem a mais inspiradora de
todas obrigatoriamente que fosse do seu
círculo do convívio eles deveriam
entrevistar essa mulher gravar
entrevista e transformar essa entrevista
no texto autoral onde ele conta a
história de vida dessa mulher que
dirigia o que a torna inspiradora
os meus alunos voltavam das entrevistas
com relatos muito curiosos
eles diziam pra mim professora eu
escolhi a minha mãe para ser
entrevistada a maioria nem escolheu a
mãe avó ea bisavó
eles diziam professora eu não conheço a
história da minha mãe eu não sabia
professora que a minha avó havia
enfrentado tantas lutas para que a nossa
família estivesse
viva e unida eu lembro de ter ouvido o
depoimento de uma aluna que diz
professora
eu não entendi por que mas depois que eu
fiz a entrevista com minha mãe ela ficou
pedindo pra ouvir a gravação repetidas
vezes
uma outra mãe me confessou que aquele
momento da entrevista foi pra ela um
momento de reaproximação com o filho e
que ela se sente muito orgulhosa de
saber que ele o tinha como uma mulher
inspiradora
eu lia 150 entrevistas que foram
realizadas e os meus alunos perceberam
que aquelas mulheres têm histórias de
vida de superação extraordinárias
muitas delas muitas começaram a atuar
como trabalhadoras domésticas aos 10 11
anos de idade
para ajudar no sustento da família
muitas superaram história de violência
doméstica de abandono estupro toda sorte
de dificuldades mas seguir um firme no
objetivo de serem os sustentáculos
daquela família
a beleza daquelas histórias foi tão
surpreendentes que nós entendemos que
elas não poderiam ficar engavetadas
e nós pretendemos tão logo a gente
consiga um patrocínio publicar um livro
e já tá prontinho com essas histórias
porque a gente entende que contar a
história dessas mulheres é preservar a
identidade daquela comunidade contar a
história daquelas mulheres é produzir um
documento histórico sobre aquela
comunidade em ceilândia
assim com a realização do projeto
mulheres inspiradoras
os meus alunos puderam perceber que as
mulheres têm sim grandiosas
contribuições a fazer
e elas têm feito essas contribuições
embora a gente tem uma cultura machista
que não divulgue e não celebra essas
realizações como deveriam
nós temos uma uma cultura com a qual os
meus alunos perceberam que não devem
concordar
é uma cultura que reduz o que diminui a
mulher que a transforma em objeto que a
subestima e que também acaba cooperando
para uma outra cultura que faz com que
no brasil segundo dados do ipea a cada
hora e meia uma mulher seja morta pelo
simples fato de ser mulher
isso corresponde a 472 mulheres mortas
ao mês 5.664 mulheres mortas por ano
são dados muito assustadores pra gente
não levar em conta que o que eu percebi
com o projeto mulheres inspiradoras é
que a gente obteve muitos ganhos
um dele foi receber o prêmio nacional de
educação em direitos humanos que é dado
pela secretaria de direitos humanos da
presidência da república
nós recebemos o prêmio professores do
brasil que é dado a professores com uma
prática pedagógica inovadora
nós concorremos dentro de seis mil
oitocentos e oitenta trabalhos inscritos
mas eu posso afirmar para vocês que o
que realmente encheu meu coração de
alegria foi perceber que é possível
fazer uma educação que liberta que
emancipa que provoca transformação
social e eu percebi que realmente me
alegrei muito quando notei que quando a
gente decide fazer a diferença
os resultados positivos aparecem o meu
desejo o nosso desejo é que todos nós é
que estejamos decididos a fazer a
diferença onde quer que nós estejamos